mm-hmm and this is from Martin
Lippincott okay and it has to do with
the temperature of the universe you have
said many times on Startalk video that
the temperature of the universe is
around three degrees Kelvin and I was
wondering how the temperature of the
universe is measured and if it is an
average temperature of all the universe
or something else
thank you that's an excellent question
so it's basically it's it's you can
measure it precisely but obviously it's
much hotter in some places than others
right like inside of stars of course but
you can go far enough away from all
stars in all galaxies and you're in the
middle of empty space where nothing is
nearby right so you're not influenced by
nearby sources of energy when you do
that you will receive energy that's
coming from deep space the universe
itself when you measure that energy you
get three degrees on the Kelvin absolute
temperature scale as it's very cold so
baby yeah
so because Kelvin is absolute zero right
yeah Kelvin said I don't like negative
numbers no he had cogent scientifically
it was even fear negative numbers the
way Americans do right I get so angry
every time I walk into an office
building and you know three two one you
look at the elevator Bank right and then
it's lobby and then there's LL and yes
and I think we have a perfectly
legitimate system for representing
floors below ground negative 1 negative
2 thank you they have it in Germany they
have it in France they in Europe they're
not afraid of negative numbers right
floor minus 5 it's not that big of a
deal not only that accounts but they're
apparently afraid of night put
parentheses around a negative number
that makes sense cuz now you're talking
about my money I don't want to see a
minus sign in front of me when you're
dead you're just a parentheses man but
that's pretty cool
so in these dead spaces you are indeed
able to measure the energy of the
universe itself exactly and that energy
is the three it's actually 2.73 degrees
to be
yeah we just round it to three just
rounded up between friends is three okay
good